Let's focus in more on this issue of how we're
treating members of the military right now.
Um, I, I'm truly sick of the current president
mocking and ridiculing members of the military
and just generally
not being good to people in the military.
Uh, the latest is that Trump mocked Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander Veneman in his first public
appearance. Since his hospital visit. Specifically,
he mocked Veneman for wearing his military
uniform. Then he also mocked last week's witness,
George Kent for his bow tie. Take a look at
this
please. I don't know him. I don't know. As
he says, Lieutenant Karen, I understand somebody
had the misfortune of calling him Mister and
he corrected them. I never saw the man. I
understand now he wears his uniform when he
goes in. No, I don't know. VIN Dimon at all.
What I do know is that even he said that the
transcript was correct and if anybody reads
the transcripts, I had two calls with the
president of Ukraine who by the way said there
was no pressure whatsoever. There was no anything
they don't know. They probably think they
can't, they probably can't even understand
what's going on with this country. But then
men, I watch him for a little while this morning
and I think he, I'm going to let people make
their own determination, but I don't know
Veneman I never heard of him. I didn't know
any of these people other than I have seen
one or two a couple of times they're ambassadors,
but these are names that are taught like Taylor,
like Kent with a nice bow tie. Wonderful.
About time. Maybe I'll get one for myself
someday. I don't know who Kent is. I don't
know who Taylor is. This
is how you know they're beat. In Trump's case,
I don't think he actually has the attention
span or the cognitive capacity to sit through,
to listen to, to understand the witnesses,
the devastating testimony from people like
Lieutenant Colonel Veneman and today from
Gordon Sunland. But that's another story.
But look at the trend on substance. Republicans
are enabled to refute the obvious bad acting
of Trump and the people around him with regard
to Ukraine. And that will become even more
impossible after Gordon Sunderland's testimony
today. And then we get to Trump, who again
is going after members of the military despite
claiming that he's all about the troops attacking
the late Senator John McCain because he got
captured and tortured and Trump prefers military
heroes who don't get captured, uh, attacking
and fighting with the parents of a soldier
who lost his life as an army captain serving
the U S military, implying that veterans with
PTSD just aren't strong enough.
As I mentioned earlier, calling all sorts
of generals who have actual knowledge and
experience clueless claiming he knows more
than the generals. He knows more than the
intelligence community. He knows more than
everybody who serves the U S in some way,
shape or form, claiming that he's donating
money to veterans to get a PR benefit and
then not actually donating the money. There
is no limit to the sickening buffoonery but
it is so acutely disrespectful to a group
that Trump said he would respect. Trump said
he would support them, but more importantly,
this is a group, forget about Trump for a
second because he'll eventually be gone. This
is a group that Republicans in Trump's party
claim to respect and support. Where are the
Republicans on Trump's constant and persistent,
disregarding disdain for members of the military?
Like Lieutenant Colonel Veneman. Why can't
they say, Hey, you know what?
I don't think Trump should be impeached, but
there's no evidence that we should be a sailing
Veneman. His character, the, the, uh, attacks
on him are not based in any kind of fact and
Donald Trump needs to stop right away. I would
like to see them come forward and say that
now as far as [inaudible] uniform, this is
not my area of expertise. I was under the
impression that if you're an active military
member, if you go to court or government proceedings,
like house of representatives proceedings,
you're supposed to wear your uniform. I was,
I mean, I, I'm going off the top of my head.
If I'm wrong, I will gladly, uh, correct myself.
But that's the impression that I was under.
And I truly don't understand where this is
even coming from and why not? We're hearing
pushback by the way. Uh, Trump, you know,
criticized a Veneman there for correcting
Devin newness.
Who called him Mister and said, actually,
I go by Lieutenant Colonel. Um, we looked
at that video earlier on in the show and it's
extremely enjoyable. I hope that you will
check it out because it is a, it's something
else. A Devin Nunez getting visibly uncomfortable
when he's corrected by Lieutenant Colonel
Veneman. But Trump again, why are you going
after members of the military all the time?
And, and really when you're under impeachment,
the focus is what the witnesses were wearing.
George Ken's bow tie and Alexander Veneman
military uniform, you know, they've lost or
you know, they simply don't even understand
what's going on when the focus is what the
witnesses, the devastating witnesses to Trump's
narrative. We're wearing clothes that Trump
found unusual or worth commenting on. The,
these guys are pathetic.